see you in the lead chess list
g4 c5 d5
yeah so we might get a bononi now it
depends what black does
okay it's knight c3
yeah and there's a lot of different
setups we can do here if you want to be
really sharp you can go e4f4
but not right now i'll do e4
bishop e7 so usually in the bononi the
bishop goes here
to control this diagonal
here though how do i want to play this i
do want to play a foursome
let's just move the bishop out
and again i'm going to try and be greedy
for this huge center and ask black what
they intend to do about it
with the bishop on g7 there's this
there's a clever tactic with b5
but here that doesn't work unfortunately
yeah b5 here i can take i've got support
from the knight
so knight fd7 okay let's
keep developing
six controller with a4
i mean again you can see look what these
bonds are doing to black
right all the squares they're taking
away
and if your opponent does some some
system of development you're not sure
how to handle just
i mean follow these principles go from
the center get the pieces out
another question is when to strike with
e5
actually just to restrict a little more
i don't want to allow this straight so
i'll just play h3
the other knight comes to d7 now i'll go
e5
and you can see right they're all stuck
in this tiny box
cup
what's the way to do this
i really want this bishop to contribute
somehow
so how do i do that
actually i like this so i have an idea
so
d6 is under fire
ah now i can take it do i want to though
now i think i'll leave it as this for
the moment
and just bring my bishop out um
i've played i've played a few 2200s and
some 2000s
i'll be happy to accept another 2000 if
they come up most of the challenges i'm
getting are from
people under 2000 though
so yeah you have to be a bit careful
here
watch out you always have to watch out
for this b5 break in the banoni
make sure you have something ready for
it
but here i think i'm prepared to handle
it
[Music]
the bishop comes out
i want to bring the queen up here that
gives me mating ideas
actually what is black doing after queen
c3
yeah so e6 there's knight f6
which still looks very good for me but
actually he's sick so bishop i can take
on f7
d6 also wins material
let's do it this way actually d6
and up it takes now the queen's attacked
and made his threatened
rookie 5 covers the mate
i know it's just a matter of breaking
through take
this is double check
okay
good game
and again i mean you can see what these
pods are doing to black
it's a recurring theme